[intro music]
With no further ado
give it up for Neil!
[applause]
Good morning John, it's Tuesday May 1st
That was New York Times Bestselling Author, Hugo Award Winner, Nebula Award Winner, and all around
awesome nerdfighter guy Neil Gaiman!
Now I know that you are a writer and that you hang out with writers and that you always have good writers
on Brotherhood 2.0
But now, I've got one!
I may have had to wait in a very, very long line
to get one
but I got one
and he's saying hi
Congratulations to Coe! LA Times book award, that's a big deal!
Congratulations to you, John, for getting nominated!
And since I know a lot of the nerdfighters are Neil Gaiman fans,
and I know a lot of the nerdfighters want to someday be writers,
I think I'm gonna share with you a clip from Neil's lecture that I surreptitiously captured
Someone asked him if there was really anything better
than seeing your name on the spine of a book
And having watched you go through this, John, I can attest that he is right.
I'm actually pretty sure that you fell victim to Gaiman's Law, which says that
as soon as your first book is published, you will go to the bookstore
and open the book to a random page, on which you will find
possibly the only
typographical error in your entire book
and then you will want to kill yourself
so here's Neil talking about being an author
It's not another day at the office.
It's magic
It's, You know, I can't think of - there's nothing else I would want to do.
Um, it's every bit as good as you'd think it would be
But, it's like one of those things, that when you're
a kid, you think, "If I just did that once, who would ever need anything more, ever?"
It's like when you're fourteen and you finally figure out what sex is
[laughter]
and then you cannot for the life of you understand why adults do anything else.
So there you have it!
Thanks for challenging me to write more songs
As a commenter pointed out, it is, actually kind of
difficult and requires lots of creative energy, so
I can't guarantee anything
Uh, sometimes you just draw a blank, right?
So there were other reasons besides Neil Gaiman that I was in Helena, Montana
[Hank, singing ominously in the background]:  ♫ Helena Montana ♫
That was weird
did you-
[singing in the background]: ♫ Helana Montana ♫
Whoa, oh!
Oh - I - Okay, I think it's time for a song!
♫ Helena Montana, Helena Montanta ♫
Helena, Montana. Helena Montana
Gold and cows and chopping trees, these are the industries
of Helena, Montana
They serve your eggs with butter and there are peeps in the gutter
Oh, Helena, Montana
Helena, Montana
We played Frisbee at the capitol and looked at lots of belt buckles. Helena, Montana.
Check your guns at the door, fat guy at a candy store, Helena, Montana.
Helena, Montana.
Well I don't know if that was anything like as catchy as the Helen Hunt song but maybe it'll
bump it out of some of you guys' heads
Still no progress on that "me not being paid for my work" front
And I'm very excited that Coe Booth thinks I'm hot
and I'd like to say hi to Francesca Lia Block
And to all of the other amazing people who said hi to me in the last videoblog.
Hello to you all!
We may not be famous, but we got famous people on the Brotherhood!
I'll see you tommorrow!